Now that we have those two classes
in place, the last step to getting
the core data structure set up
is creating our managed objects.
Creating our managed objects is
actually easier than you might think.
Because, in fact,
we did most of the work already
when we created our model file.
Now, all we need to do in order to
generate our managed object files
is click on our data model,
click editor and
then click
Create NSManagedObject Subclass.
>From here we select the model file we'd
like to create entity classes from and
then the entities or
objects we would like to be managed.
Here will select both Note and Notebook
because we want to manage both of them.
And then we'll click Next.
And then Create, cool,
and here they are taddah.
But wait a minute,
how come there are four files here?
So when you generate
these managed classes
two files are actually created for
each entity.
You have a class file and
you have an extension.
The extension file contains code that
matches up with your object model.
You never ever want to write anything
into these extensions because Xcode
will overwrite them and recreate
the class if you modify the model.
So, it's good to write any code inside
of the managed object class itself.
Now let's just move these down to
the model folder where they belong and
feel free to pause the video here and
go ahead and generate these managed
object classes on your own.
Great, so,
this Note class is looking pretty bare.
What we need to do now is that add
an init method to this class can create
usable instances of itself.
We'll add in a convenience init which
takes text, a string with the words new
Note init and an NSManagedObject
context called, Context.
Then, what we need to do is
create an NSEntityDescription.
An entity description is an object that
has access to all the information we
provided in the entity
part of the model.
And it's needed in order to
instantiate any managed object class.
>From the entity description,
we call entity for name.
Which takes in the name of the entity,
so in this case, Note, and
the context in which we want the Note to
live, in managed object context context.
Then we can call the designated
initializer, which is the initializer
for NSManagedObject, the superclass,
which takes in the entity description
and the context in order
to create a new instance.
And you can see the parameter name says,
insertIntoManagedObjectContext,
which is where the instance will live.
Remember that every single core data
object needs to know its context.
Lastly, we just initialize
some properties,
text will equal text which we
can remember is the new note.
And creation date will get
initialized to NSDate object
which is just the current date.
We'll put in this fatal error
in case no entity exists and
the entity name we're passing in.
And we're done.
I'm also just going to add in this
variable which is just a formatted
version of that CreationDate
property we initialized up there.
It just makes the date
more human readable.
And that's it.
We can now just do the same thing for
the Notebook class.
Awesome, why don't you give it a try?
Before moving ahead to the next video
make sure you have both inits and
get no warnings.